okay so I think we can get started so
welcome to the third day of
this workshop and today I think we are
going to be talking about uh challenges
uh in omics analysis related to human
disease and we start our first speaker
with Ron Shamir from Tel Aviv University
that we'll be talking about the
multiomix integration
thank you
so
a common challenge that
we all share is to make medicine more
personalized
so while currently we use
the same drug for all and some are
health
some are many are typically unaffected
and some are even
damaged we want to use additional data
omic cmrs Etc in order to tailor a
disease that the uh so that each
individual will be
so I'm going to talk about three or four
stories and as this will be short I will
not be very technical so the first story
is a work of nimrod a PhD student in the
group
and the motivation
is the tcga like data sets where we have
multiple layers multiple modalities of
data for a cohort of individuals
uh which is potentially
extremely powerful we have tens of
thousands of samples across dozens of
concert types and six or seven omics
however the these omics are extremely
different in terms of their number of
features the statistical properties Etc
some of them are even
not numerical
and the question is can we use these
together in order to
in our case Identify some types of
cancer better
and
we looked at the literature and actually
they are quite a large variety of
methods for multi-ohmic clustering uh I
won't get into the different uh
types but here a few representatives for
each of the types we even noticed that
there is a subfield of machine learning
called multi-view Methods which
essentially does the same but it was
applied for other contexts and many of
these algorithms were not tested on
genomic data at all so we set out to
Benchmark this methods on 10 pcga data
set each of each of them containing a
few hundred
samples if you're on with patients and
we focused on three omics gene
expression micro RNA expression and DNA
methylation and we set aside the
clinical data there are about
two dozen clinical parameters available
for each patient and we put them aside
for evaluation
and the evaluation was done by in two
ways first of all since we had the
survival information of each individual
we could look at the survival curves of
the different clusters after we
clustered the samples and use the log
rank test to assess the different
significance of the difference between
the Clusters
and they were also about six clinical
parameters that were common to all these
cancer types and we looked at the
significance of uh
of the appropriate test for between the
Clusters
uh I'll show you the results soon
because while developing while doing
this Benchmark we realized that maybe we
can do better and we came up with a new
network based approach so here is the
the setup we have we look at a
particular omic and the profile of a
particular patient and then
we want to compute the similarity of two
patients in this omic and we do this by
this radial basis function where it is
normalized
by this factor which is the average of
the similarity of a sample I to its
neighbors where we focus on the K
nearest never this is the ETA
that you see here the similarity of J to
its neighbors and the overall the
similarity between the two samples
uh and the
relative similarity between two samples
is uh this function but it is normalized
by the total similarity to the neighbors
for J and for I
so
in the integration step so this is done
separately for each omic and the
integration step is the simplest
possible is just averaging this relative
similarity across the owners
so here's the overall algorithm we could
compute the similarity as we just
described and then apply a spectral
clustering
in to determine the number of clusters
the only twist that we do is rather than
take the
eigenge method which looks orders the
eigenvalues and looks at their
differences and picks the largest we
multiply this by I
the index of the of the difference in
order to nudge the number of clusters
slightly higher
uh and note that this approach can
directly address missing data with no
need to imputation because
we just sum over the average over the
omics that are available for each pair
of patients
okay here are the results so we compare
this on 10 concept types and
compare the method that I showed you
before in Nemo is in the last column so
here in the first row you see the number
of cancers for which there was
significant difference survival between
the survival curves using the log rank
test and Nemo had the highest number
when we look at the
number of omics where there was a
significant clinical enrichment in one
or more of the parameters we see that
Nemo is best tied with three other
methods in terms of the number of
clusters it's sort of
in the middle there are good methods
that create a large number of clusters
other do well with less and in terms of
run time it is the second fastest the
only faster respectful because we use
the spectral algorithm as a as a
subroutine
here is another view of the result so
here rather than counting the number of
significant values we summarized on the
x-axis the
log of the log bank p-value and on the
y-axis the average number of significant
clinical parameters again averaged over
the 10 cancer types and we see that Nemo
is on the Pareto optimal Contour
together we they are mkl and MCCA so
there's no absolute winner across all
methods but the name wrong does well
here is one specific example this is a
amen a cohort of nearly 200 patients the
same three omics
there was full data for only 170.
patience so what you see here is the the
survival curves for the five clusters
that the Nemo found
and here Nemo performed better than all
the other algorithms
better than using just the 170 samples
with the full data
and better than any single omic
separately and when we compare the
results to the French American board
classification of AML
and to our known subtypes APL we both
got a good match
so to summarize this part we performed
the Benchmark of multiomi clustering
some multi-view methods for machine
learning did well
uh and we developed our own methods that
uses a kernel similarity
of neighbors and
simple integration it was best overall
but not always there were cases where uh
other methods did better and also there
were cases were using a single or subset
of the omics was better than using all
omics so this begs the question of
whether clustering the way we do it is
the right approach and we get to it in a
minute one thing that we found out in
the process is that the log rank test
that it is broadly used uses the
asymptotic
approximation of the chi-square and on
the type of data sets that we have here
a few hundred samples
the results of this approximations are
two optimistics and we actually
developed implemented the method that of
use a permutation based based exec test
moving on
to another approach to this method
following this study this is a joint
work of minor de Nori from the group
and here what we as I told you we
observed the sometimes not all omics be
behave the same for example here you see
the result of a breast cancer
and you see the three omics and uh
the the yellow cluster seems to Cluster
well in micro RNA and mRNA but not in
methylation on the other the on the
other hand the purple cluster seems to
be doing well everywhere
uh so
maybe we should not include all omics in
all subsets
so here is our approach which we call a
Monet and the idea is to select the
ohmics per cluster
so a module will be a set of patients
and a set of omics so here of a module
beta contains these three patients and
it is only uh includes the the blue
omics or only a model Alpha contain
these samples and it is covered by omits
one and two and we developed a method to
hill climbing method to to search the
solution space this is an empty heart
problem so here is the approach suppose
this is a
the solution in the center you see the
solution that is I think this diet
the center we see the solution the
current solution and one thing we can do
is add
or remove
patients from omics
so here are or switch sample between
modules
another thing that we can do we could
either add an ohmic to a cluster so here
now is this uh beta is now both blue and
red or we can remove so Alpha is now red
only so we do we do this hill climbing
approach and until
and
we are stuck and here are the results so
we apply this to the same uh 10 cancer
pipes and what you can see here is the
set of omics that were included in all
the clusters of all samples so they were
relatively few where all three ohmics
were included so there were some that a
single ohmic was best and a few were a
pair of omics
turned out to be beneficial so indeed
the very different from the clustering
that we saw before when we look at
survival we see that uh
our new method
performed equally well to Nemo
and when we look at the enrichment in
clinical parameters and the same they
are both Nemo and moner are doing best
but interestingly they are not doing
best on the same set of Concepts
so there is an advantage of of using
both here is one application so here we
look the data of the Single Cell
clustering
we look specifically at expression and
methylation data for Mouse embryonic
development
and
you see here
the eight cluster that we found for
example the first cluster was gene
expression only
the last three clusters where both omics
there was one cluster that was the DNA
methylation and only DNA methylation and
when we look at the at the
cells we realize that it is similar
across different Gene layers and this
suggests the what is actually known that
even if the expression is changing the
methylation
still persists and this developmental
stage
so to summarize this part we developed a
new model that generalizes clustering
where the set of omics is selected for
each cluster
it is it is equal to Nemo overall but in
terms of the types of
cancers on which it is doing best they
are they are not the same so our
suggestion is to use this
complementarily and this begs the
question whether more General models
could be
beneficial here
Switching gears let me present the work
that was done by Nimrod and led by
Jonathan a master student of the group
so here is the setup uh when we are
talking about multi-ohomic integration
there could be a situation where we have
a single Army and multiple data sets
like we see in red and this is a
well-studied batch correction problem
there could be a situation where we have
the same data set but multiple omic like
we just described and the most General
situation is where we have multiple data
sets and multiple omics and specifically
what we will focus on here is the
situation where we have the gene
expression and DNA methylation but we
will assume that
the DNA methylation and gene expression
are on different data sets so one set we
have gene expression another data set we
have DNA methylation and we wish to
integrate
so here is how we do it we assume that
we have a set of samples for which both
data sets are available
and we
for each gene we look at the
DNA methylation signal within plus minus
10 KB from the gene we actually exclude
the gene body and the F5 Prime utr the
sides and for the rest we summarize the
signal and and we use lasso to
to obtain the
regression coefficient
and we pick the 2000 models with the
highest R square
that this this will be the result of the
training for the embedding as I said we
have one data set for with DNA
methylation and another regime
expression and we use the 2000 models
that you we started with in order to
predict the expression from the DNA
mutilation for data set one and then we
restrict the genes to those that are
highly variant both in the gene
expression and in the DNA methylation so
we end up with a set of typically of a
few hundred genes and then we now have
the predicted gene expression and the
non-gen expression from the other data
set and we embed them together into a a
d dimensional space using a canonical
correlation analysis we call this map of
the intent
here are the results
first results so we looked at 11 cancer
types from tcga
and what we did here is to train
to use the training on 10 cancer types
leaving aside the 11s and then do the
prediction on the 11th and the embedding
and to evaluate the result since we know
the matching of the of the patients from
the DNA methylation and the gene
expression we can look at the closeness
of the points representing the DNA
methylation and the gene expression in
the embedding and the measure that is
used in the literature for this is
called the fraction of samples closer
than the true match in the embedded
space and of course this the smaller
this fraction the better the results so
here are the results We compare
themselves to
[Music]
ligers and mmdma in several versions and
on the y-axis we see the the the score
the fraction of samples closer than the
two matches and we see that the intent
is substantially better than all others
in virtually all cancers
here is one example so this is the
column identicalcinoma so you see here
the U maps of the DNA methylation and
the gene expression and here is the
embedding of 10 it is very well mixed
foreign
[Music]
there is also substantial mixing mm DNA
but overall the results of intender
better we marked 10 random points 10
individuals on both the expression and
the methylation and you could see that
the typically the the two omics
embeddings are near to each other
overall
here is one other task that we could do
so here we looked at four cancer types
together
and the uh we trained on the remaining
seven cancer types and then the
embedding
and again the
first DTM was two orders of magnitude
better than in the other methods but
here since we have several cancer types
we don't only want to see mixture and
closeness but we also want to see if the
methods separate between the omics
between the cancer types so here is the
you know the mixing result similar to
what we have seen before again intend
it's substantially better and here the
samples are colored by the four concert
types and we see that
intent provides a very good separation
actually here mmdna profiles a good
separation as well but other methods
less so so
here is one sample one final example so
here we looked at the
melanoma samples
and we some we partition the data set
into two halves we used half
the methylation signal and half for the
gene expression signal and what you see
here there is a survival plot for the
resulting clustering result so the DNA
methylation by itself does not do a good
job in separating the gene expression
profiles are doing much better in terms
of separation and when we take the
embedded
DNA DNA methylation profile they are
doing equally well as the original gene
expression profile even though as I said
these are two
and this joint set of samples
so to summarize this part we developed a
method to integrate DNA mutilation and
begin expression profiles from different
data sets
using a combination of
regression to learn the individual Gene
models and the CCA for embedding to a
joint space
here it was crucial that we knew what
we knew how to match between the DNA
methylation and the particular Gene
uh this was quite useful however this
could be generalized to other data Pairs
and we see that on the on our test the
the advantage of using this data were
very beneficial one thing that is left
to be done the embedding phase we are
now using CCA but there are a variety of
uh good the single ohmic multiple data
method once we do the embedding we are
back to the single ohmic multiple data
methods and we could
apply any of these methods
and see perhaps we can do even better
uh how am I doing
okay so I'm wrapping up skip the last
story
and just thank my group and thank you
for listening
well many questions here uh
the second part of the story which
which two can which cancers would you
say were were the closest and which ones
were the were the furthest
so uh we looked at 11 11 of them which
uh yeah
oh so you're talking closest and
furthest into we didn't compare
similarity between cluster types we
compared in the Second Story we looked
at the set of common omics to each pair
of cancer types
so we can look at this example
let's see
so here are the in this case we have a
four cancer types and according to
intent uh
the
sarc and the melanoma are the closest
yeah we haven't done this globally but
this is definitely something that can be
done
I caught up with loss in the morning
part
um so when you say that some
sample some patients cluster better or a
group better using only one omic data or
multiple omic data is that affected by
the quality of the data or the lab
source of the data or
how does that happen is it a different
type of cancer and that's the reason or
so you know there could be certain uh I
don't know patient groups that are
affected more by a particular subset of
data types maybe I don't know
our micro RNA is not relevant to this
particular subtitles and therefore we
don't expect the clustering this was the
reasoning we saw empirically that
sometimes it is better just to use a
single omic than using hollon so this
Monet was trying to generalize this and
see if there are subsets that do better
and my last question would be in like
the last part of your story where you
talk about the melanoma I was wondering
if you look into other subtypes of
melanoma like Akram melanoma that it's
still the same cell that there are some
similarities but we also know the origin
is different there's no you'll be like
no we haven't done this I'm not sure
that there are enough samples in
tcga to look at subtypes but we can look
it up
first question
very important work uh so in the first
project I think believe it is AML you
found different groups with different
survival rate did you try to look what
is unique with respect to the group of
the higher survival rate compared to the
lower survival rate with respect to the
DNA modulation gene expression and Mr
mRNA profiling
but we don't think we found something
common across cancer types we looked at
some particular examples like the the
the one that I showed for the AML and
there we could match it to to known
subtops but looking at the particular
omics uh no we haven't looked at it
that's a good point
it's very nice I mean I had two quick
questions maybe one the most important
one maybe even the last part
uh
the regression model of the methylation
expression can you comment on how
specific that is to cell types and data
sets and things I understand you learned
what a specific model for each data set
but is there Universal relationships
that you can leverage across data sets
or use transfer learning and the
question is is that is it video data
specific or are there ways to maybe you
know even cross-leverage public
resources other data to yeah so
the way we thought about it is that this
is a
we expect something to we expect this
relation to be Universal so if we apply
the our method to a subset of the
cancers then we use everything else to
do the regression
it might be more powerful if we can
identify the most appropriate cancer
subtypes but we haven't done this yeah
okay so thank you very much huh
so uh we move on with the next speaker
which is that Roderick
and we will be talking about the
epigenetic logic of Gene activities yeah
I will I will I will not say this the
organizers for inviting me here uh I
apologize because I actually
um break in total with the the topic of
this of this session because I'm I'm